[Music]
this Pope is visiting a completely
different country to his predecessor
[Music]
I want to hear him loud and clear
recognize what the church has done to
the citizens of this country people have
a deep sense of fate but they're just
not connected with church
[Music]
to Pope John Paul Arland was sacred
ground when he visited in 1979
contraception divorce homosexual
activity and abortion were all still
illegal the church held sway they used
to call it Catholic Ireland a place of
pilgrimage for the faithful but not
anymore the land of saints and scholars
has witnessed a social revolution the
church that once controlled this state
now battles to find a place within it
it's a seminal moment for Pope Francis
to be arriving on Irish soil the last
Bastian of Catholicism became the first
country in the world to legalize
same-sex marriage by referendums
[Music]
[Applause]
but then voted by a landslide to lift
the ban on abortion yeah we're it's
certainly a different place and and this
Pope is visiting a completely different
country to his predecessor in coffee
shops like this one a generation
mobilized to change the direction of
travel campaigner una Mullaly says the
church hasn't moved with the times what
I see is a Catholic Church that wants to
actually consolidate a more conservative
base and pursue an ideology that is very
much out of step with how people are
thinking the more they pursue that the
more meaning the church loses for people
in this country the number of Catholics
has dropped from 95% of the population
in 1961 to 78 percent today but few
attend mass on a regular basis the
church has fallen from grace vilified
for 9000 reported cases of child abuse
by priests and for imprisoning single
mothers immortalized in the film the
Magdalene sisters 30,000 women were
locked away
Delia Mel Ryan spent 30 years of her
life in a Magdalene laundry we were
taken to the site by her son Peter he
was born soon after she arrived here I
feel very very sad about us
like I couldn't bear to do that to an
animal this kind of tells the story of
Ireland you know you've got religion and
one side yeah but you had what was going
on inside this laundry that's right
indeed where the the poor mothers would
be slaving from 7:00 o'clock one morning
at 7:00 in the evening can't lift her
head from a dress boring work Condon's
talked one of the communities laugh or
joke he was so sad environments being
Peter what was their crime what was your
mother's crying
she had a baby out of wedlock that's
centralized s and when you think of
horse it's just adjust itself to those
children when they got a chance the way
they treat them was horrible and they
got away with what they wanted to do
with them Delia was one of thousands
taken from her home during the night by
her own father the priest had told him
they couldn't have a scandal in the
parish Peter had a child of his own and
his mother was an old woman by the time
he find her he's still searching for his
baby sister and suspects the church sold
her to a family in America I think she
could be alive still wish draw the
deniers that were ever anybody sold are
from this country to America now we just
call houses the remains of hundreds of
other children were find buried in a
septic tank at the mother and baby home
where Peter spent his first four years
he says the Pope must apologize for the
church who do you blame for this I blame
society and the stage and the religious
order the religious order ran this
country the way they wanted us this is
knock on the west coast of Ireland they
don't come more religious than the
pilgrims here
this small time boasts the National
Shrine and little else but religious
curiosity shops there's no other
counties that I allowed town that I know
of that it's just all novice just
complete your religion make it up they
built an airport here after Pope John
Paul Kim they're hoping their second
papal visit will be good for business
before the scandal is broke them as
crowds they're coming here with grace
and then like all of a sudden you
clapped her hands together
it was nearly haft and again and that
the authority of the church that they
lost that and the other people I suppose
you know people don't know it the more
education than there were years ago like
you know and they're making up their own
minds about what their religion is or
what their Fiat is even here in the
religious heartland of the West a new
generation has questions about the
church's willingness to adapt to the
social uprising people look to the
church sometimes and it's a completely
wrong view they think you know that the
church doesn't care that there is just
shut down and they have their own
opinions of what we what our beliefs are
and some of the times those opinions and
those perceptions are wrong like say for
example the most one that we get from a
young person is why does the church hate
gay people the church doesn't hate gay
people you know and I think that's
really important for the church to put
that message out there you know we have
to be all inclusive we have to be
welcome every single person the church
is desperate to reconnect with thousands
of cultural Catholics they only attend
Mass at Christmas our four christenings
weddings and funerals when I speak to
parents who only bring their kids to
make their communion their answer is
always look I have my own faith I pray
to God and I never good life and I think
that's where we need to be to encourage
these young families and then journey
with them to what I like to call the
summit the celebration of Eucharist so
that they're understanding the
importance of Eucharist and and how much
that they can get from us some have
given up on religion but not on faith
John was the poster boy for art of
surfing he grew up attending Mass every
day during Lent but swapped the high
church for the high seas with a computer
in Brazil in South Africa in France and
I would have traveled to Hawaii to surf
big waves that was what I was really
into that's living the dream John but in
your case the dream wasn't enough yeah I
was in Byron Bay in Australia you know
just living to surf and have a good time
but I just had that I didn't understand
it at the time but there was an
emptiness inside and I was searching for
meaning and just for love and I bought a
Bible and I started to read the Bible
from there
he belongs to a small independent church
now John says he's not religious but
does have a person of faith and that
those are two very different things I
think we've had the influence of the
Vatican the Roman Catholic Church for a
thousand years
prior to that there was a monastic style
Christianity within Ireland
and from Patrick Brendan column kill all
these guys we were people of the book we
were people of the scriptures and that
was all about relationship knowing
Christ walking with him and less about
religion and so I think there's an
opportunity again for us to go back to
that to go back to what the true the
true message is this is still a deeply
spiritual place but for many faith is
more personal now they feel the church
has not adequately addressed the painful
legacy of the past there is generational
trauma in this country that is the
result of a collusion between the
Catholic Church and the state
and while there have been reports and
there's been some redress it hasn't been
tackled yet the church you know the
couple of church Oh 1.3 billion to the
Irish state for redress with regards to
abuse you know the fact that one of the
richest organizations in the world just
simply you know it is kind of dawdling
on that is reprehensible so is there a
place for faith still in the public
square in Ireland in 2018 I think in any
progressive country there is always
place for all sorts of faiths and all
sorts of religions what there isn't a
place for is for a religion to dictate
education policy for religion to be
embedded in the Constitution you know or
for those beliefs to be imposed upon
people which they have been for so long
in Ireland so will Pope Francis have
something to say to those who suffered
most at the hands of the church I want
to hear him loud and clear and to
recognize that he understands what the
church has done to the citizens of this
country which I'm speaking about washa
has done to them to the vulnerable
there was forced to show respect to the
porpoise here to represent God here on
earth and as far fair fair lady is away
from what they're doing what would it
mean to you Peter for Pope Francis to
say I'm sorry for what the church has
done to people like your mother and you
and your sister yeah what would that
mean to you
to mean and naathan us I could close my
eyes and peace but as it stands I
chemist it said it was so so cruel
it was healed at the time as the dawn of
a new era for the church but Pope John
Paul's visit proved to be its high-water
mark when he celebrated Mass in Dublin
one and a quarter million people
gathered they can only admit half that
number this time Ireland has changed
changed utterly but some will still come
out of curiosity all these in the hope
of hearing that the church has done some
soul-searching this is the Phoenix Park
where the papal visit will begin and end
every word spoken by the pontiff why
he's here will be critical Ireland has
become skeptical about organized
religion but many people here still have
a personal faith some might even be
willing to forgive but is the church
ready to repent
[Music]
you